hey everybody and welcome to a
belligerent wild ride with stevo we've
got party animal bert kreischer he's my
favorite dude the first time we had him
on the podcast was such a hit and this
one might even be
better so strap on your seatbelts and
get ready man it is insane and i gotta
say i'm feeling particularly smooth
because i'm shaving with my
harry's shaving products this is just
what you need and nothing but i'm
telling you you gotta try this if you
haven't already because you're probably
blowing a lot of money on shaving
products that you don't need to be
blowing this is so affordable and it's
the best razors out there now if you go
to harry's dot com
stevo you get yourself a starter kit
that comes with the five blade razor the
weighted ergonomic handle the travel
case to protect the blades the foaming
shave gel and if you hurry up and do it
right now they're going to throw in a
big old travel body wash too all of this
all of this is valued at 16 because like
i said it's super affordable but you
take this deal now you're gonna get it
all for three bucks if you go to harry's
dot com slash devo i've been using man
it might be
two three years i've shaved with nothing
but harry's i
love it so support the podcast jump on
this deal go to harry's dot com
stevo and let's get into it
that one maybe yeah i sat there and you
sat there i think yeah i feel like i was
here when you guys were beta testing
this yeah yeah and it was like before
kobe came out and like you were like
coughing you just got back on tour yeah
yeah people in the comments were like
he [ __ ] picked up the rhona
recording recording is that recording
this is recording
awesome okay ladies and gentlemen
bert kreischer oh i feel so honored
because this podcast has blown the [ __ ]
up and i was i was at the i was at the i
was at the very
the baby steps of it you were our first
hit who's number one i think tony hawk
tony hawk dr drew dr drew was episode
number three however we recorded that
one prior
in a different van yeah
yeah you guys have had some good ones
i've seen a lot of i mean
i i really kind of i did poopy show and
i watched you with poopies in here and i
was i was like oh that was a that was a
great [ __ ] interview oh that that's
the one that we did on the tour bus now
we've got two studios
oh really yeah if i'm on the road we've
got the tour bus studio if i'm at home
we just bring the van over to people's
house what kind of tour bus are you
riding around on the road a prevost uh
yeah i'm i'm buying a new one i'm buying
one right now i'm so glad that you
started off on tour buses because i
[ __ ] curse you so
regularly me yeah because
because
you're the bastard who [ __ ] made me
think it was a good idea to get my tour
bus wrapped with stevo hart oh it's the
best
i don't know where you're gonna be right
i mean dude i go back and forth between
being like really stoked because we're
driving down the highway and it's just
boom boom people are still way more
famous than me so it's it i can see
where that would be annoying for me it's
like you gotta know who i am to do it
like like there's people that don't like
like i said to my daughter today i said
uh i said do you know who stevo is and
she goes her friend's like no i was like
you guys watch jackass and they're like
no and i went okay and then you walked
in she goes oh i know him and i went
then you have watched jackass and she's
like oh i mean yeah but we don't like we
don't watch all the movies but of course
i know who he is do you have a picture
of yourself on your tour bus yeah yeah i
have pictures of myself everywhere
i literally in my man cave all i have is
pictures of me and then and i didn't
even think it was something wrong and
everyone's been like man you really love
pictures of yourself i was like who do
you put up in your house like what am i
gonna put up my pictures of my daughters
they're in their regular house this is
me
yeah well he has himself tattooed on
himself three times um
more than that
right um
i i go back and forth with the with the
tour bus and and what i've settled on is
uh we've got a new light up sign
on the door that says
it's not okay to knock please do not
disturb that is a brilliant sign and
then you hear this
[Music]
is he in there
all the time he's sleeping he's sleeping
yeah i know
it's really crazy
it's really crazy you have to really tap
off a part of your brain
i think it's good i think it'll it
forces you to live
in in your heart and in the moment
because you get annoyed a lot but if you
do enough and you have yourself on your
bus and people look in your bus and they
knock on your bus and you pull up to a
gas station and everyone has never heard
of me but then they're all the biggest
fans and i got to take pictures with
everyone but it teaches me to always be
kind to people because
and it forces you to be there and then
and then when you're not on your tour
bus and you're saying like i was at a
show at red rocks i was seeing jimmy
buffett and this woman was being
extremely disrespectful to me and not
that i was me but just to me she was
being a mean person to me and it was
nothing about anything
being because she knew who you are
uh
we had parked our we had parked our
sprinter van back uh backstage because
i've been at red rocks night before and
she
and i told her i said where's our
sprinter vans right there we just need
this access she's like you don't get
that access and i went i said oh no i
performed here last night she goes no
you didn't and i said no i did and she
goes honey let me tell you something you
will never perform at red rocks and you
have never formed a red rocks and she
goes keep walking and i was like and
then i was like i was like well i'm not
going to change her mind like you know
so i just was like i was like okay and
then my my manager and my wife [ __ ]
jump on her i'm like guys [ __ ]
it's she simply just is doing her job
and so and i thought because i'm in
public so much dealing with sometimes
people that can be somewhat annoying
i've really learned how to live in the
moment and just go this isn't my battle
this is this is there's nothing i'm
going to do to change this woman's mind
and so i was like and it was and i and i
really honestly think it's because every
now and then you'll be and you're here
and there'll be a guy that walks by and
sees that your curtains open on your
tour bus and it'll be like bird bird and
you you want to be like hey man i'm in
the middle of telling my buddy a story
but then you're like hey man i'll come
out say hi i don't know i don't mind it
how long do you go on uh a run for
aggressive like
eight months
the last one was eight months and we i
was home
i was home maybe eight times
i was so i was i may be home
six times i was in austin more than i
was home dude
when we did the first podcast with you
which by the way was our first hit the
first podcast we ever had hit a million
views really on youtube like and then we
had segura not too much of a hit
well he did well he just didn't do that
here's the thing about tommy tommy is i
always i've always said this i don't
understand why people like him
he's he's the he's my favorite human
being i love this guy more than anything
but there's the things i get out of
tommy i don't
like he get all the [ __ ] that you get
out of me on a podcast he gets out of me
in real life right like i'm fun as [ __ ]
i like to have a good time i'm sneaking
hot dogs in my pocket like there's like
i'm a fun [ __ ] guy
but he also there's a part of me that is
very sincere and
and insecure that i that i share with
him that he appreciates and he knows me
really well but like that like tom tom
has no problem going on a podcast and
under delivering
like
i don't know i [ __ ] love the guy but
i always say to him i don't understand
why people like you because i know why i
like you but why does brad pitt like you
like like what did brad pitt see because
he didn't see the thing i saw it's like
it's like when people say they they like
my wife i go you're not seeing oliver
like i know everything about that woman
like i like that you like her but you
don't know her like get to know her how
do you what brad pitt likes him what do
you bret piss tom's one of tom's good
friends
can you imagine hanging out with brad
pitt all the time and maybe like you got
a boner
like there wouldn't be anything wrong
with that right
what if like you had just had a
bluetooth tablet then of course you're
gonna have a boner you're gonna have a
huge rock hard raging boner like i do
when i take bluetooth tablets and i
bring lux to bone town okay because
that's what happens why because blue
chew tablets have the same active
ingredient as both viagra and cialis
except they only cost a fraction of the
price and if you ever wondered hmm
is taking a bluetooth tablet a lot of
fun i can assure you it is a lot of fun
i love it i love it my girl loves it
when i take my bluetooth tablets i show
her my blue tongue and she's like whoa
she's so stoked and man
i boner really hard just saying i bone
her really hard and you got this
opportunity right here to get an entire
month's supply of bluetooth tablets
absolutely for free all you have to pay
is five bucks for shipping and you
consult with one of the medical
providers online you get your
prescriptions super easy without an
annoying
inconvenient trip to a doctor's office
do it all online super fast you get a
whole month's supply of bluetooth
tablets on the way to you if you go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
stevo you're insane if you haven't
jumped on this deal already so jump on
it bub
bluechew.com
use the promo code stevo for a whole
month's supply of bluetooth tablets all
you pay is five bucks for shipping
you're gonna thank me and so will your
boner now let's talk about brad pitt
oh really yeah they're like best friends
i think and so yeah i know brad pitt
liked his comedy and uh
and clearly he just hadn't seen me do it
and and uh because i'm so much better
and so so i was waiting for someone to
laugh at that joke
but uh but um he
saw stand up like to stand up had they
had the same agent and he reached out to
his agency and was like hey man can you
give me tickets to tom show and then
[ __ ] and he went this whole time show
and i saw that on instagram yeah that
was really [ __ ] cool yeah because i'm
a huge brad pitt fan i mean who is it
and i'll tell you what i'll be honest
with you is because jackass made brad
pitt cool
brad pitt
it wasn't legends of the fall
hold on
yes think of all the movie stars that
have had great movies that are [ __ ]
right
he did when you guys kidnapped him in
gorilla outfits in jackass you were like
this guy's got a sense of humor he made
like bro it made him a bro he likes cool
stuff snapping was not in a gorilla
outfit and then we did the gorilla bit
after oh yeah yeah the kidnapping was
just curious about that he's like we got
brad pitt why are you covering his
[ __ ] face
and bam made a point
it was so cool at the end when he took
his gorilla mask off that was brad pitt
and then and then i was like oh yeah you
could have done so much crazier stuff
with those gorillas and then just use
that last clip
right and when meanwhile he was like do
not go easy on me
like [ __ ]
that's what makes you like brad pitt
like those moments you know i saw him
driving one of his motorcycles down
sunset one time
dude the gl the leather gloves he had on
i think i think about those once a week
i mean he's just a badass [ __ ]
yeah i mean there's look
i'm a sucker for celebrity okay like i
am i like sure if you want to tell me a
story about my trainer trained tom
cruise for like
like all the mission impossible movies
all the all the big jack reacher all of
them when she tells me tom cruise
stories i should [ __ ] listen i love a
good tom cruise story and so
i i love i i'm when i moved out to l.a i
was a sucker for celebrity i thought it
was that was cool it was cool that
someone was famous and then you see them
and you'd be like you're like that's the
[ __ ] guy i mean i i saw mike tyson in
an elevator one time and i was like it's
the [ __ ] heavyweight chair champ of
the world that's mike tyson possibly one
of the greatest boxers that ever lived
he's in an elevator at the lemley center
where i'm going to crunch and he's just
in an elevator and i was like holy [ __ ]
what year was that because it was night
that was uh 2000 it was 2002
so that was a gnarly mic
yeah and it was right after that was
right after um i remember it was after 9
11 because i remember being in an
elevator and someone was saying some
stock brokers on the phone and he's like
no no we need to buy
southwest
southwest is the company that is going
to stand out during all this stuff with
911 and i remember going i had never
heard of southwest
and then i should have bought southwest
southwest airlines yeah those are the
tips that you get that you get you got
to like take advantage of it i bought it
i've the stocks i've bought i've [ __ ]
up every one of them oh my god dude i'm
cursed oh yeah like like like
stocks
[ __ ] up
like any investment [ __ ] up because i
invest in it
i invested in clean coal out of alaska
kfx was the name of the company i
invested in like like when i had no
money i invested ten thousand dollars in
them and they just tanked i invested in
motorola i invested in nokia i invested
in hong kong telecommunications i
invested in
like i would get an idea and i'd be like
i'm like hong kong
that's china right it's not and i'd be
like they're going to need a lot of
phones one day so i invested in it and
just yeah clean coal i'm being good for
the environment
everything's tanked don't you guys have
money people that tell you like good
investments oh now i do but i don't even
know what it is like i don't even know i
like i don't even know i was standing on
two bears the other day i i was i felt
bad that i wasn't like donating money to
charities and stuff
and i we talked about on two bears then
i called my business manager and he goes
you have a foundation and i was like i
do
can you donate like hundreds of
thousands of dollars every year of
course that's how he's like i mean i'm
not saying you're like waking up going i
need to donate but like you're you and
leanne donate consistently and then i
was like oh we and i and i think of the
things that we've given money to and i
was like oh yeah we totally have donated
what am i talking about i'm not i'm not
set up in this business to be like the
i like the artistic things i like ideas
i like making ideas happen i like making
people laugh but like the business the
minutia of the business exhausts me yeah
dude anything insurance related
even remotely administrative like i i
can't even
help statements i have to pick and
choose pockets of when steve doesn't get
the look on his face like
yeah do you know that that i still have
not
opened up a single email that says pnl
or
financials
it gives me anxiety yeah leanne leanne
left town and she had a bunch of stack
of things she goes those are some bills
i'm going to need you to open them i'm
going to need all the checks
we defaulted our [ __ ] power guys i
did make a mental note to say to you
that i want to sit down and actually
open up these pnls because i want to
know what's what like what's going on
a profit loss statement for the six
businesses that he owns
profit and loss it's like what's going
out what's coming in like uh the balance
sheet like to see where you're spending
money on to be like don't do that
do here like the revenue streams that
are coming in focus on that
yeah i don't even know how much
something's burning is costing me i'm
just making it i i did same thing when i
bought my [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] rv like
to use as a tour bus yeah i thought
because this was my my thinking i had
been renting a tour bus from this great
company right like uh with the came with
the driver prevost everything
i thought man it's so [ __ ] expensive
like i'm like what it cost like fifty
thousand dollars for like two and a half
weeks of using this tour bus i was like
man [ __ ] that i'm gonna buy an rv
you know i'll buy the rv it'll pay
itself off in no time and my dad was
like well how much of the 50 000
from for renting was for gas was for the
driver
and i was like
i don't know
yeah
i have no idea so i don't even know if
it was economically wise to buy the
piece of [ __ ] rv to rap
here's where here's where it got to me
it got to me is that i
had spent i have to date spent so much
money
on in tour buses and now look it's
like i mean i've been on a tour bus i've
been on i've had it my own tour bus
meaning you know for everyone listening
when you get a tour bus you can get it
for a month but if if you need it for
like if you need it for the month after
you might as well just rent it for the
middle month also because you may not be
able to get a tour bus
and so i have
i've had tour buses consistently
on
lease
i think consistently for now for like
three years during covet is when during
coven
i i'm on lease or did you you know just
buy i'm just renting them i'm just
renting them and i rent them weekly i
rent them for the whole time like i
still have mine we're off for two months
but if i gave it back i might lose a
tour tour bus
so so like you buy one that's i'm buying
one now i just i just went to dinner i
just went to dinner with uh with the
tour bus dude and uh my tour bus guy
actually and i talked about buying a
tour bus because i was like i want
i want my own i just want everything i
want and i want to make it the way i
want it because right now i can't really
[ __ ] with like storage is a problem yeah
it's a trailer
uh we do not use a trailer anymore we
did and it was just i think we had a
rough time in amarillo in an ice storm
and i was like and i think we had to
stay there or something and so we
stopped using trailers for fully loaded
i had four [ __ ] tour buses i got four
[ __ ] tour buses like that's because
there were so many communities so many
comedians and then i had a party bus
where everyone could hang out and so
like we'd get done and there and then
everyone would party at the venue a
little bit and then we'd all go to the
tour bus partying the tour bus
bus call would be like three everyone
would start driving at three and then
when everyone got tired we'd have all
the buses pull over we'd get off the
party bus everyone going to their own
buses so it was it was no and that party
bus was more fun than any bus i've ever
been all my life nicer captain seats
just [ __ ] sweet i bet
um so so
to buy a pretty boast you're like what
1.5 million like
i guess i don't know i mean i'm getting
they're sending buses to me now like
pictures and uh
and and
it's just the shell i'm just buying the
shell right now and then you're gonna
just yeah and then and then i design how
i want it in the middle and i and i know
i mean i really want here's the other
problem is this is going to sound this
people are going to understand this it
won't make sense
i sleep in bunks i don't sleep in in the
back bedroom i sleep in bunks with the
guys because i have this weird thing
they were trying to explain it last
night it's not that i'm
during the pandemic i wanted to make
sure everyone lived on the bus so i
didn't want to put myself in a nicer
room and then go hey guys we're all
living in the bus but i'll have the big
room so good luck
pedestrians so i was like i'll sleep
with them so that i know exactly how bad
it is so if i feel we need hotel rooms
then we definitely need hotel rooms but
we didn't need hotel rooms i really
enjoyed it and there's a part of me that
really enjoys
not missing out like when i was they
were saying some of those people were in
there worked on travel channel with me
and i forgot but when i used to get
really nice hotel rooms on travel
channel but i just wanted to stay where
the crew was because i wanted to have
fun with everyone i didn't want to be
off of my own in a different hotel room
where people couldn't get access to me
at the four seasons i wanted to stay
with everyone else but on this one on
this tour bus i think we're gonna it's
it'll be foolish right into a star coach
with a bedroom in the back and bathroom
in the way way back i already know how i
want to set up bathroom in the way way
back with the closet you gotta have two
bathrooms yeah bathroom in the middle
and and then and then uh and then six
bunks or
yeah yeah the thing about me sleeping in
the bunks is that when the curtain
closes i'm like i'm out i'm out
it's a good sleep and then all of a
sudden i'm like
like i'm in a coffin and i really like
yeah people will be walking by and
they'll just see my hand come out
because i'd get claustrophobic about
being enclosed oh no what's crazy is i'm
claustrophobic but not in those bunks
and my boob strap will tell me that like
i i
when i'm on a bunk i get zero deep sleep
and zero rem zero
zero and it's all it's like zero eight
hours of zero can i tell you can i show
you my whoop recovery from late that's
your phone yeah where's my phone oh my
phone must be in there my whoop
recovery's in the 80
because i switched over tequila
that's why because like a sugar thing a
hundred percent what's the sugar so
sugar my my recoveries were in the 35 45
percent consistently if i drink i
switched over to tequila i switched over
to tequila and my recovery is through
the [ __ ] roof i sleep sound as [ __ ]
none of that like drunk morning sleep
where you're like god damn it man i just
can't get comfortable i want to just go
back to sleep i'm all over let me go
back to sleep on tequila if i wake up i
go i'm going back to sleep and i go
right back to sleep i feel no hangover
whatsoever and i'm burning like
700 calories in the gym
for an hour workout i'm killing in the
gym because it's tequila a game changer
nose i drink tequila soda with splash of
lime yeah and it has changed i mean it's
like i it's [ __ ] so clean and i got
all my blood panels back my liver is in
the normal ranges and i'm like dude it's
tequila what's your hrv on your whoop uh
i wish i had my [ __ ]
goddamn thing because thieves was in the
hundreds of hrv is that good
it's like the best yeah you're really
healthy though um
that was when i was on no sugar no flour
then i got back on sugar and flour my
hiv went
all the way down and now i'm once again
no sugar no flour i thought my hrv was
like 35 is that yeah that's hiv
okay yeah oh i got that too i got that
too that 35 i believe i believe that you
have that and it's not good okay
yeah that would be my hrv i would
imagine i'm not not now hiv means heart
rate variability we all know this
because of whoop which is [ __ ]
fantastic whoop is the best and i don't
know if they're sponsors i got rid of my
apple watch because of the whoop they're
they're they are the best
uh wearable track traffic tracker you
can focus
fitness tracking device known to man i
wish i had my thing i would love to go
through my numbers with you i'm sure
it's in the [ __ ] man cave yeah
whatever
but like i want to know my i want to
know my hrv now i'll text it to you when
i get i'll text you i text rogan my
recoveries every morning i go [ __ ]
tequila
i mean what are rogan's recovery he's
like a hundred percent so so the i mean
i don't i'm
i hope i'm not speaking at school but
the only reason anyone knows about whoop
is because of us yeah because we did
sober
october and so
so we got we were the first generation
of dudes getting whoops so when we got
whoops we were like
it was like first of all we didn't
understand any of it
but
joe rogan put a [ __ ] dent in it he
his whoop at the end of every day must
be like
if you're wondering whether burt and i
really do love our whoop straps i can
tell you that is a yes it's simply the
most sophisticated fitness tracking
device known to man plus the new whoop
4.0 strap has a waterproof charger that
slides on i mean dude it's the best and
they will hook you up with 15 off at
check out plus give you the woop 4.0
band completely for free
if you go to woop.com
w-h-o-o-p dot com and use the promo code
stevo joe rogan bert kreischer stevo
these are three wildly different
personalities all raving about the whoop
strap i'm telling you it's the way to be
it gives you all the insight into your
health your rest your sleep your calorie
burning more than you can get from any
other fitness tracking device so if
you're not wearing a whoop strap i'm
telling you you're blowing it so one
more time for 15 off your membership and
the free whoop 4.0 strap with the
waterproof charger it's whoop.com with
the promo code stevo now let's get back
to it
i mean
his [ __ ] like
you'd get you'd get his uh his his
activity you know you start activity and
you can track it yeah and it was just it
looked like the [ __ ] swiss alps
and he would burn he would keep his
heart rate 10 a.m he would keep his
heart rate in the red like at like 171
for an hour straight and you and i'll be
like what the [ __ ] he would work out so
[ __ ] hard and then his recovery like
a hundred percent green like he would
just go like he he's a different animal
he would work out like a beast and then
when he decided to go to bed he would
sleep for eight hours exactly and wake
up like no i never got to eight hours i
was always at like seven hours and
fifteen minutes i i i get grumpy if i'm
less than eight hours oh i can't i slept
great last time i slept nine hours last
night and uh [ __ ] slept awesome panic
attacks in the morning but whatever
that's normal dude speaking of rogan can
i officially thank you in person for the
kind words you said about me and my
podcast and my comedy i don't even
remember it
you had a tony hinchcliffe on last time
you're on rogan it's like the first 10
seconds
well yeah
because rogan said he said i want to do
a podcast in a sprinter van he said i
want to make a podcast studio in a
sprinter van you said yes stevo does
that yeah yeah well i mean my feelings
about you are genuine so i don't i don't
i mean that's how i feel about you i i
i try and i mean there's a few people
i'm
impressed by you know like where i go
like oh god they're doing it good you
know and it's for a number of different
things um
but i you you consistently impressed me
and it's like i said i didn't say this
on the thing in there but like it was
really cool when cbs we both did pieces
of cbs
cbs came over to my house and they were
like yeah there's like this great and
they're like do you own all these
cameras like you know i can i tell you
i'm really uh jamie was saying this
because i'm really impressed by stevo i
was like yeah he's like he's like a like
a businessman like he knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing and i was like oh yeah i
was like oh i could spend my whole
interview talking about stevo if you
want
i [ __ ] love the guy
i mean i i'm a businessman i just don't
know what my businesses are doing
you don't need to be you don't need to
be like look [ __ ] steve jobs didn't
know how to make an iphone but he had
the idea and then he was like send it to
asia they'll figure it out whatever
right or we sent it to the room and he's
like guys this is what i want you go
like this and it does that and they're
like huh you got to be like i think when
you're
on our side of the stage
you got to have big ideas right and
you've got to have the right team around
you to help you execute those big ideas
we we spoke with mark cuban about this
about about surrounding yourself with
people who fill in your gaps
dude
i'll tell you my number one on my list
is my wife my wife is so
she's so literal so functional and so
smart like she when we did fully loaded
um
she she was so she said we don't we're
not making any money on this we're
putting all our money back into it and i
said why she goes it's only successful
if we do the second one like it's not
successful you view one yeah it's only
successful if you do 10. and if you want
to do 10 you got to do two but if you
want to do two you got to put your money
back into one so that's why we got all
the tour buses and had all the like
extra treats for everyone we had uh
catering travel with us we had a juice
bar travel with us wow can i ask you
what was the mechanism for preventing
people from poaching the show with their
cell phones do you did you have a
mechanism for that can't stop that yeah
because like
i i i lose my mind i wanted to call you
i wanted to call you about it because i
know i know that that was because we
reached out to you to do it obviously
right and i wanted to and i wanted you
to do it i wanted you to do it for two
reasons because i know one of the i am i
could be wrong but i know one of the
things that
is important to you in your career is
being taken seriously as a comic as a
comic and i thought one of the great
things about this tour would be that you
are sitting with uh inarguably 12 of the
best [ __ ] comics in the country right
day in and day out who would then get to
see you performing as a comic and and i
thought it'd be good for your for
everything for you and i thought it
would be great i just thought it'd be
great and then and then and then i was
gonna call but leanne told me not to
because
uh
i said they go uh stevo really wants to
do it but he's working on his new hour
and he's worried about you know people
stealing it on their phones and putting
it online and i wanted to go and i was i
totally asked so i'm going to call him
because look i'm working on my new hour
too right and i and but that's just part
of like
doing business these days is that people
are going to do that and you just got to
hope that i mean that people don't
search it out and leanne goes don't call
him
how would you feel if steve asked you to
do something and you said no you gave a
reason and then he called you i'm going
you're right you're right but i wanted
to call you so back so i was like i was
like i think it's the wrong decision i
want you to do it because i think it'd
be so good i think first of all you
everybody did eight shows over time we
did almost 100 000 people
in two weeks would have seen how [ __ ]
great you are and and and all these
comics would have seen how great you are
and i think it would have been great to
watch your brain work with the way we
were operating we had a whole production
van shooting content making content
there was so many opportunities for
content i kind of want to see how your
brain worked with like we you know we
had churchill's downs to ourselves we
had uh we had these electric bikes that
we were taking through uh through the
arenas like i wanted to see your bikes
from electric well we had one electric
and we had one from
uh from 75 uh super 75 one super 75 so
it was but it was that's what i wanted
but look we're always we're doing it
next year i'd love to have you come if
if you change your mind i i i think that
it
could that there's a way for me to
approach it that that could work um and
then by the way thank you for all those
kind words uh as it worked out this this
uh this last time like i i
did well because um i had my own like
theater run going and it it just was it
was uh in a business sense it just
worked out way better for me the way
that i did do it yeah yeah yeah
but uh but yeah i would love to take uh
take an approach that
that works like that the the thing about
my comedy is that it's multimedia yeah
and uh you know like the i don't know we
had all those aspects up there i was and
i literally because big j wanted um he
wanted the opportunity to do crowd work
for us to have a camera and a big screen
up top so he could play like play him
who he was talking to and so we had like
we would have totally accommodated you
and i and i totally get it but um but
yeah i mean i just i and that's why when
i say things about you positive on rogan
i mean all of it i i think you're a
great dude you're really inspirational i
appreciate that so much man and uh i
feel the same way about you i'm so
so [ __ ] impressed can we talk about
the extent to which you are [ __ ]
killing it okay like i don't say well
i'm off for two months so i have panic
that i'm not killing it at all like i'm
just like what am i doing with my life
okay i mean like i'm gonna guess that
you're two months off or by design
because you've got so much press to do
to promote your your machine movie
coming out on netflix uh no we don't
know where it's coming out yet
i thought there was a netflix thing no
no
we have a movie we have i have another
movie at netflix but um that's uh just
that's just uh we're hoping to release
it in theaters but we're you know we got
this whole ukrainian russia thing going
on then
right yeah i've never been more
interested in a war i was like can we
just [ __ ] can someone do something to
make it stop so i can put my movie out i
know that sounds selfish but like he's
like what the [ __ ]
right what [ __ ]
so you've got your pro your podcast the
burt podcast you've got your podcast two
bears one cape which is like wildly
uh
bigger
we did not i don't think sugar and i
first of all i don't think cigar and i
ever thought
we definitely never thought we'd be
doing arenas i know for a fact um but
when we started that podcast we had
really good healthy careers like doing
theaters and so it's doing solid
um i don't think we ever thought it
would be where it is now and and i think
we just got lucky with a couple clips
that um that are really funny clips like
the kool-aid clip jennifer aniston clip
isla shoot and dice like there's there's
like we just got lucky and i think it's
just
you know
just being consistent and this is the
whole thing about a podcast being
consistent
doing it doing it consistently
and just showing up and doing it and
you know some episodes are stinkers and
some are weird like we we talked about
being dads yet like a much couple months
ago and we both ended up crying and like
and we did not see that coming but it's
like but it's i think we're up for the
run and the fun of it and and
and
we both make each other laugh
hysterically like we both find each
other absolutely hilarious and so
we got really lucky with that podcast
yeah are you looking at the views and
like [ __ ] that they didn't hit nope
you're just like
i don't i well what no that's not by
design i'm just saying like the way we
shoot them i don't remember what
episode's airing on what day so i never
know
uh i never know what's going to air so
like uh
uh this week
um this week was
the days that we just got done fully
loaded and we did a podcast episode
about that and we did a podcast about
that and we talked about i think we
talked about charity but it's like we
gang shoot him because he's in austin so
we'll shoot four at a time so i don't
and they're in two days and usually we
the way we do it is the first ones with
coffee and the second ones with either
weed or alcohol and so i don't remember
what i say and and so i don't remember
anything i mean we had one where we put
butt plugs on our ass and i did not i
don't remember that i remember recording
it
because we were just partying we smoked
we lit a joint we had and we were just
partying and then leanne's like did did
y'all put butt plugs in your ass and i
was like oh did that come out today if
so i don't really i don't look at the
views that kind of
you know
that's more for the ad sales people to
look at um
okay so
remember when when i guest hosted uh two
bears in one cave huge episode it was it
was it was [ __ ] the hardest that that
i've laughed it was a huge episode and
we
we
i mean i still to this day
uh i still to this day laugh
can i please see your dick right dude so
i had this crazy thing happen i went to
the um gathering of the juggalos
right i was i hosted the main stage in
the bucket list gathering of the juggler
the most incredible experience
i come out i come out on stage and and
i'm doing like crazy tricks and stunts
whatever all i'm hearing from the crowd
show us your butthole
sure is your butthole and i'm like at
first i was confused and then you know
that's where it went out and then i i
mentioned some of this no no they love
it they like they love it they really
they really
mean it they want to see your butthole
they love by the way i'm never liked uh
insane clown posse fans more than right
now right so
my natural reaction to that is well i
mean if that's what they want and that's
they care about that like who am i to
deprive them of them so my next time i
go out on the stage and
i [ __ ]
i spread my butt cheeks like
like then
past the point of where it hurt and he
gave him a heads up too so they all
pulled their phone out are you serious i
had no issue with that you had no
problem with that yeah this was this was
for them now and on top of that there's
like a whole you know like the media
looking between the crowd and the stage
oh dude pull on and the next the next
day
shaggy who's one of the i i met him i
met him yeah he um
he sends me a
photo that was taken from the crowd
because man you weren't kidding about
and this photo is the most shocking
[ __ ] thing you have it on you dude
like uh it's the most [ __ ] shocking
thing you've ever seen yeah he talked
about it for a good like two minutes
that he's gonna show his butthole so
everybody's just ready to go
and here's the end result okay let like
i'm gonna in my text i'm going to
search the word cavernous
really
big paper
because okay you killed me
were you sucking in or something
i showed my girl and and uh
she's like you can fit the whole
microphone in there like that's an
o-ring that's like a [ __ ]
but it's not but that's the thing is
that it's not
[ __ ]
my butthole
it's the it's the lighting it's the
lighting can i tell you i'm really
impressed by their lighting on that
stage right i really like this i think i
use similar lighting in my stage i'm not
are you kidding me
who takes that picture and doesn't post
it right that person posted that photo
that's not good
they're like this one's for me that's
like the top of the seo yeah it's the
stuff of legends now did you did you
hear the story about how
scott randolph types in
johnnyknoxville.com and finds it to be
available for purchase
no and i [ __ ] bought it
are you serious yeah
okay watch this
i'm gonna type in johnny knoxville.com
all right it'll it'll just it should
just pop right up
and
johnnyknoxville.com it's got an age gate
the first thing you see is uh ru18
and uh
man how do you not have a good cell
phone signal at your own house it's the
tree
we have a great wi-fi okay are you over
18. yes
um
and we made we made it a particularly
small okay you know that i'm going to
show you what [ __ ]
what loads up dude because i have it
nice and handy
[Music]
oh that's [ __ ] great
[Music]
that's [ __ ] awesome
is that your butthole
but it looks like it is because of the
same shirt
yeah and um i mean i'm very proud of
that that's that's what i love about uh
the jackass energy
i'm curious i was so curious i don't i
don't want to know the answer i think
but like
i i i was so curious if like
when
uh when you guys first started doing it
if there were like teams like the the
philadelphia team and the watchmobile
absolutely and there was a little bit of
cause i remember like
there were it seemed like now when i
watched the first one you could see a
little tension between certain people
like when uh when
i'm so bad at names and i love these
guys so much but um
uh danger aaron
and and bam almost caught in a fist
fight one time yeah and they had to
break it up and they're like did you get
into a fist fight on the third movie
yeah yeah and so maybe that's the one i
saw and so and so i was like that was
the same day bam broke my nose too
really
and so i wonder like i was wondering do
they have were there squads
and then i was like i wonder if if there
were squads when everyone came in
the for the new guys if it was a
weirdness or if it was like you guys
have been there so long you're like this
is the deal the weirdness was when
uh knoxville
and tremaine
announced to the the og cast that they
wanted to bring in new blood that was
younger people and like you know like
none of us were stoked on that idea yeah
i can imagine i can imagine you wouldn't
be
and as it played out like we we we
resisted it we
we pushed back and they just weren't
having it they they said no that's how
it's going to be so that's how it was
and uh day one on the set with the new
guys like
they just were so stoked to be there
they were just like the you know like we
just felt
we fell in love with them right away so
so it all it all
kind of dissipated it was fine now
speaking of the new guys and and this is
something that was uh pretty crazy you
mentioned i had poopies on my podcast i
did poopy's podcast poopies is a real
dead poopy's podcast you know you i
listen to you talk about poopies
and i i do i i knew poopies from um
yeah so i was a fan i'm a fan i am a fan
of jamie o'brien's and poopies would be
on his podcast i knew poopies i knew
part of poopies and then i saw him on
jackass and i felt like i got to know
more of him then i saw him
on your you maybe you were on his
podcast
i know i just did his and it's not out
yet so okay so i saw him on you on yours
and i was like i was like oh poopies is
an interesting person and then when i
did poopy's podcast
i could not stop [ __ ] laughing he is
a real he is an authentic i told him he
should get a macarthur grant you know
they give macarthur grants to like like
a lot of people a lot of professional
clowns will get a macarthur brand right
right she's got a lot of money in being
a clown but if you're a really good
clown like the guy from sesame street
yes clown ever i'm so glad you know that
yeah yeah best kind of he had him i
think he had a macarthur grant i'm not
vomiting he's actually a cirque du
soleil clown who's better than bill
irwin but what's the macarthur grant
they give you like 150 a year
to just keep pursuing what you want to
pursue 150
yeah 150 000.
and they just just go hey just keep
doing you you're so special we don't
want to break you we don't want to break
we don't want the world to break you
because what we think is your art form
maybe isn't um it's underappreciated
it's under appreciated so we want to
make sure that you can continue thriving
and making and doing you and so and
poopies is
a hundred percent that human being right
when i started my podcast with poopies
like like one of the
first thing that just falls out of my
[ __ ] mouth i'm like so you're really
dumb
it's like the first thing i said and
and there was a lot of uh
kind of
criticism in the comments and stuff
people were like man that really rubbed
me the wrong way steve you know like
[ __ ] you steve up for saying that yeah
and i i deserved that criticism i
deserved that backlash i i it was just a
it was a thoughtless and uh shitty way
to start the conversation
he's not dumb he's just
poopies does the world he's like i mean
i mean disrespectfully he's like theovon
theovan
is is is
sees the world
in his own unique way and there are
people i know theo very well and we work
together on a number of shows there are
people that write off theo to maybe not
being uh not being in not maybe not now
but back then they write off the over
not being in the moment or not listening
or not paying attention but man when he
spoke it made the people listening laugh
hysterically
theo's so
quick so
he's quick but he's but man you know
theo says things i'm saying this real
i think a lot of people think you know
theo spends a lot of time writing
sometimes he just says things efficient
that are just that come out
hysterical where and it's the way
his brain actually operates you can't
change that you can't right by that his
he's
he's just being an authentic artist like
an authentic artist
and
booby has that
authenticity of like he was talking
about he was telling me a story i for
about
about setting off bottle rockets in his
ass and he goes do you want to know how
i came up with that idea and i couldn't
stop laughing because i was like i think
i got it but
like i think i i'm pretty sure i can
ballpark it but sure tell me how you
came up with that idea of poops but he's
i had so much fun with him yeah i love
that guy man i love him too and and
i shouldn't even try to defend myself
for just coming out of the gate saying
you're dumb
but he's dumb
i don't think he's i don't think he's
his lovability you know like he's he's
so lovably innocent and naive he's very
i'm saying that as not an insult if
that's possible yeah well i think i
think i i can get written in that in
that in that same stroke of the brush
where everyone goes um bert's not a very
introspective person he's not a very
thoughtful person in like his actions or
his behaviors or his words i say [ __ ]
up [ __ ] and i don't think things through
but like but like yeah poopy's uh
he
he said something that my assistant is
25
and uh
we were having dinner that night and
we're having a drink and he starts
giggling i go what and he goes
i said the poopies and the thing i said
how old were you
how do you remember beer runs and he
goes yeah [ __ ] yeah i remember beer runs
he goes as a matter of fact
i might i might say i i i quit doing
them a little too late in life and we're
like how old were you were you for your
latest beer run he was 27 and we're like
27.
my assistant's at dinner he starts
giggling or what he goes i'm 25. like i
would never do a beer run poopy's just
doing do your beer beer runs two years
after this day for me yeah i just called
his poopies
eyes 33 34. yeah i i was having a
conversation with steve on the bus yeah
poopies was sitting over there
and i was like hey yo dude and poopies
wasn't even looking and i was talking to
steve and he thought that i was talking
to him so
every question that i asked steve you
just hear poopy's going yeah kinda
he's like oh no way
oh i [ __ ] love this guy oh no you
can't create him and you can't try to be
him right like you can't try to be him
you just are him i'm like i'm talking to
steve he's like oh hell yeah and then i
keep talking like dude i changed my
number i i i hit him up like two days
ago and he didn't know like who i who it
was and i was like hey poops are you
available to film on the 26th in san
diego he's like oh hell yeah dude who is
this
dude that's an authentic person there's
no [ __ ] and there's no
pre-thought-outedness of it you know
which is so original in this business is
someone who's not pre-thinking out like
i remember i remember uh
uh
whitney cummings told me a story i won't
say names but it was another comic when
he told cummings got her uh tit leaked
like so some guy had a picture of her
that she had accidentally exposed on
instagram and
she had there was more stuff and she was
afraid he was going to leak it to the
internet so she got in front of it and
she posted the picture of her she was
listening someone's threatening that
he's going to post this i'm not going to
let him do that i have the own power
this is my tit i posted on instagram and
then that day i posted all right she
posted a tit on instagram no she didn't
like twitter twitter twitter twitter and
um and so
i then posted a picture of my balls
where i'd kind of ruptured a testicle
and
and
i
at no point did i see that as like and a
comic called her and he's like
i was [ __ ] brilliant is it real
and she was like is it real and he was
like yeah like what are you trying to
sell and she was like
what the [ __ ] you talking about and she
told me about that and i went
that's crazy like so many people
wondered like was joe coy and chelsea
handler like a real relationship or
they're trying to sell tickets there's
because that's so much of this business
not obviously it was it was a real
relationship it lasted for a year but
but like so many people's brains work
that way and poopies does not and it's
so refreshing in this [ __ ] business
of like where even me and you can get
caught up in the thought
if you because you can work you can find
some workarounds for things yeah you
know like [ __ ] you know i remember
going in for surgery for my elbow and i
had to sell tickets at red rocks and i
went i'm gonna make this work for me and
i [ __ ] filmed my promo going into
surgery going under and
like there are some guys that and
a lot of us that will try to think
things through that is not poopies by
the way that is such a [ __ ] hilarious
poopy story that you're having a
conversation with steve and he's in the
front going yeah he's like oh hell yeah
dude he's like sick
no way like he had like four things that
like he would just say oh what a [ __ ]
great dude dude blocks off an entire day
to shoot and then says oh dude i got a
new number who's this dude
or no you got the number you know you
know that was a whole other story dude
yeah yeah that's a dude it's it's crazy
um dude you uh you rave about your
management yeah i do constantly yeah i
love them i love well i love my whole
team i look at this business differently
now so this is way and i kind of i mean
like you borrow from other people so
i'll tell you everything that happens
i'm going for a hike in fryman canyon
sugar calls me allie wong just fired
three arts and i went why
the [ __ ]
three arts of publicity no no there's
dave becky and some other guy but
they're really big they're
one of the top five biggest management
companies they have everyone to tell
louis they had louis they have burr they
everyone
so um i go why does she fire three arts
and he goes she said she doesn't need a
manager and i went what he was like i
think the business is changing i think
she's just gonna do her own projects no
ali doesn't have a podcast but i i'm
like okay
since the girl fires three arts and i go
why why the [ __ ] are you doing that and
he was like i don't know man i the
advice i was getting from him wasn't the
direction i wanted to go in like i
wanted to do my own things i go to your
house and you're doing your whole thing
by yours you're you're running and you
have a great team around you and i
started going i started thinking like
okay so what do i want no i'm in a
unique situation and that my manager
judy is
is
i i hope this doesn't sound too flowery
but is somewhat of a visionary in the
way she sees her clients careers and she
never stops thinking about her clients
she has i think like four clients me
whitney sebastian and taylor tomlinson
and she
only thinks about business for us that's
all she thinks you'll get texts in the
middle of the night uh uh i i just i
have an idea a long time ago she long
time ago she said um you need a portion
of your beer sales and i was like [ __ ]
yeah i do and she was like we that's
that should be one of our focuses well
if we're fully loaded i got a portion of
the beer sales and suffice to say in a
festival that i did not plan on making
on any money i made a fair amount of
money because we sold a [ __ ] load of
beer yeah and so but that's the way her
brain works and so i would never get rid
of judy because i need her brain when i
created the um drive-in movie theater
tour i came up with the idea
called my agent manager nick nick
newsfour heidi feingan and judy
judy my manager and i said i want to do
driving movie theaters and they're like
they're like candidly it's not a thing
now listen if they were the people that
just didn't follow through with it i'd
be gone in a second but that team was
like [ __ ] it let's see if we can figure
it out they got an edm company who does
electronic dance things they talked to
them we got on the phone with them we
talked to them and they're like we got
it let's get you 12 dates i
secret time i backed out of it because i
was like i don't want
everyone everyone's rogan segura
everyone was like you don't want to be
the guinea pig who tries something new
and then fails horribly and loses fans
like if it's a bad show you might lose
fans
my manager and my agent called me and
they were like hey
we know your brain and it's and it's not
it's not ali's brain it's not tom's
brain it's my brain it's a little bit of
your brain is there like
if you go out and start to try to do
something you will find a way to make
that succeed you will come up with
content that will get enough views that
will deficit fund
three failed dates why don't you do
three dates if you like them then we'll
do more but if you don't like them then
you walk away from him but you came up
with this idea and you should follow
through with your idea so i did it off
the advice of i got cold feet hard as
[ __ ] and i did it and the very first one
was in a rock quarry in north carolina
and i was like i'm done i'm in
line up we did 70 more cities i was like
[ __ ] i had a blast through the whole
pandemic i won an award for it i won two
awards for it like it was like a it was
a big game and it gave me
the ability to do fully loaded and when
i came up with fully loaded i big ideas
big swings and then took my managers and
agents and they're like let's do it and
then they set it up and i got cold feet
again i got cold feet so much hardcore
secret time i was supposed to do it a
year ago and i backed out of it because
i was like so i was like i don't want to
do it i felt like it was i felt like
there was too much ego involved and i
felt like i was pretending to be someone
i wasn't and i i was like and what if it
fails and i don't want to fail like i
was nervous so i didn't do it last year
and then this year they're like you're
doing it this year you're doing it this
year and they're like you it's your idea
you came up with this idea it's a great
idea and we you will make this work and
so it's funny but once i'm i'm i think
we're all the same type of person but
once the ball starts moving i start
operating also once the bus is going
sure i start doing things also so
in fully loaded where i got
cold feet about certain things i just
figured out different workarounds so i
was like so like first thing is i was
like i wanted the comments to i want to
make sure the comments had fun so we i
think each person got like a 3 000 gift
basket of like treats that we either got
from sponsors or purchased ourselves to
make sure that when the comics got there
they really had it and so then that made
me a little more less concerned about
taking care of the cubs one of my big
concerns i want to make sure that
everyone has a good time so taking care
of everyone but that's i love but it's
like the right team and so now what my
business move now is is those people you
see in there that is one arm of my
business
it's kind of the way you do it that's
one arm of my business and then i have
and that includes podcasting
um
all my content all my promos
something's burning and that is birdie
boy productions and then i have uh bird
inc which is my stand up and that is my
manager my agent now i mean i will tell
you right now if anyone gets an
opportunity to sign with either judy or
nick or heidi [ __ ] do it tomorrow
they are the
most brilliant
people in this business
levity levity yeah levity judy brown
levity i should say the name and uh
candidly i i i know this
and
i'm close to this because
uh my agent
adam genevizion is no longer an agent
and has now
transitioned over to liberty
transitioned over to he's a bad [ __ ]
too yeah he's a bad [ __ ] he is i like
that guy a lot yeah he's my dude looks
like he'd be selling you cocaine in the
80s in a movie right adam's the best
looks like that he's got that vibe he
looks like he looks like the guy in you
know what he kind of looks like the guy
in blow who backstabs johnny depp diego
yeah diego on the island
i'll give you everything i'll give you
everything
yeah he's good he's got those really
blue eyes yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's my guy
and uh and i [ __ ] love him and he
just raves and raves about about judy as
do you and and uh yeah
judy thinks about judy thinks about and
i know this is really inside baseball
judy thinks about this business
nonstop i don't ever
i remember i had a moment with her
it was like really telling
we had a guy we worked with and um
and he
he's i mean he said something innocuous
maybe this is horrible for me to say
he said something like yeah i'm i can't
really you know i can't really talk
right now i'm hanging out with my family
and judy and i were like huh
we're talking about business like what
the [ __ ] put your family on the side
this is business and judy and i had this
conversation where we were like venting
to each other
by the way scott and i both are like
hallelujah
all i want judy goes and we were like
going back and forth like like we found
a band we loved but the thing we loved
was
working in business right and like she
was like i'm i never stopped i i
i never stopped working i'm not i don't
one point of my day do i stop working
and going
and go yeah never
i wake up thinking about jokes i wake up
thinking about promos i wake up thinking
about podcast questions i can ask a girl
when i do the next two bears what let me
text rogan i'm gonna like i'm working
every [ __ ] second and that is judy
judy went to a kevin kenny chesney
concert the other day ever sorry for
interrupting no have you ever once in
your life had an automatic reply set for
your email to let people know that you
were out of the office
i answered who doesn't check their
[ __ ] email i'm in hawaii great from
the beach
i'm on vacation like number two i went
on a vacation recently [ __ ] worst
experience ever i'm like dude we're like
but we've like wait we're we're
deliberately accomplishing nothing is
that really what this is like [ __ ]
relaxing stresses me out relaxing i
don't get it and then what's crazy is
that is who i was as a kid like i was
when i i was like i was like don't
bother me i'm on vacation i was like
that guy and then something switched i
think was when i got the opportunity
to make money i think when i started
like
kind of succeeding and stand up or at
least i felt like the second i felt like
i could affect my career
i i then
became
singularly obsessed with it like right
well the second i realized i think i
relate to that 100
because i think we're probably both in
the same situation where maybe you not
as much as me but like when i worked at
travel channel it was a corporate job
and i couldn't really affect change for
it i couldn't get people to watch the
show as much as i promoted it it never
no one really tuned in it wasn't that
good and i couldn't make it better
because i couldn't edit it and it was a
it was a
branded show of family friendly and it
wasn't my voice and i couldn't make it
my voice and i and it was good money but
then when i got let go from travel
channel and and i remember that period
of time where i started doing we were
talking about those posters and my thing
yeah that was around that time whatever
it is 2017 or whatever when i started
taking control of my business and coming
up with ideas to better my business and
then the second it worked
i was like oh
i'll just do this i mean i remember one
i remember
i remember being in my front yard when i
came up with these my flip-flops i got
my own flip-flop and so i remember being
in the front yard and it was around that
time and i was i was getting some
traction online and i had i started
having fans and i i had a pair of these
flip-flops i loved them they stopped
making them and i went
i'm going to do my own flip-flop i'm
going to reach out to that company and
see if they'll do a deal with me and see
if i was and we were going to san diego
for a vacation with my family my parents
and i was like yeah i can't i can't go
with you guys seaworld i have a meeting
and then i go you're going to see world
or whatever maybe it wasn't sea world
but and they're like you're going to
whatever and i was like no i have a
meeting i'm trying to start a flip-flop
company and my dad's like what the [ __ ]
can i go yeah i'm up i got this meeting
with this guy we went to lunch with this
guy and talked about it and now with
three four years later i've sold a dick
load of flip-flops i have slides which
are even better than the flip-flops and
but but it was also that thing where i
go
i love these flip-flops i knew that if i
put people's foot in this flip-flop
they're gonna love this flip-flop too
yeah and so but i never shut it off i
mean i never i go to steely dan you know
what i do with silly dan oh this is my
favorite thing in the [ __ ] world wait
you're at the steeler dance concert
i find out i find out steely dan is
coming to the hollow at the bowl
and immediately i go
let's play a game
let's pretend this is burke chrysler and
i'm a burp chrysler fan i want to see
how i operate how i function the things
i do and how i could better relate to my
fans
in ways that would be helpful for their
experience come and see me the number
one thing i did which is crazy is i
bought 10 tickets immediately and i went
pre-sale is a real thing i don't i need
to really focus on pre-sale because i
want to i want good seats i wanted the
box seats and so i
am a fan of steely dan when they come to
town and they didn't promote very well
but when they come to town they've got
my money they've got they're gonna have
a big chunk i'll give them two thousand
dollars because i wanna make sure my
friends go i buy all the tickets that's
my favorite part of a pre-sale is i buy
all my tickets and then i text who i
want to go to the show with me because
i'm like oh i get to pick this is my
night i bought all these tickets so i
text thomas sandy our best friends judy
and her husband steve my trainer lacey
and her best friend who happens to be
one of the top chefs in in in the
country because it's the hollywood bowl
so you can bring your own food in so we
tell her you don't have to pay for your
ticket but you need to cater it uh this
is i want you guys to bring the wine we
need it so we organize it and then i
started going this is really fun okay i
started thinking
all right let's think about merch what
merch do i hope they have as a fan right
and as someone as also as an artist to
what merch do i need and the first thing
i thought was i hope they're selling
sweatshirts
because the hollywood bowl gets cold but
i don't want to bring a sweatshirt i
want to buy a sweatshirt but i want to
put it on there and so i was like [ __ ]
and then i started like having fun and
leanne goes if they sold steely dan butt
plugs would you buy one and i went
[ __ ] yeah i go you want to sell butt
plugs in our next season she goes we
should sell butt plugs
birdie boy butt plugs and just people
buy them just as a lark as i go and then
i started going like oh this it was the
funnest experience i've ever had
and i'm doing i do that all the time and
judy judy and i talked about it she goes
i'm going to kenny chesney i'm going to
kenny chesney i'm going to see how they
do their show i'm going to think about
it as a fan first flip it around and it
was the funnest because you start going
like oh i'm giving this i'm giving this
experience to people they're paying for
it but i'm offering this experience i
should be operating at my highest level
and if if i'm not going to live shows to
experience it from the other side of the
stage and see what's good and see what's
bad and like like steely dam was really
hard it was really easy to find their
merch right when you walked in and i was
like boom that's brilliant you know
sometimes merchant red rocks is up in
the top you're like what the [ __ ] yeah
no one goes up there but but but so i
don't know what we were talking about
but i don't ever shut down when i think
about business yeah we used to sell
stevo coke straws dude
there's so much merch you can sell you
know i sell dick pics at my shows
pictures of my deck
yeah i like that i like that
autographed dick pics that's not bad
that's not bad i remember when you were
a little kid how you there were those
those uh [ __ ] pens right side up it's
like the chick with the baby
turn it upside down the bikini goes away
yeah yeah i still dig pants
i got shorts you turn upside down
there's my dick sky's the limit with
merch because as a fan i love wearing
like i'm wearing two bears merch right
now tommy's a real game changer that's a
pornhub
thing okay um i'm wearing two bears
merch right now but tommy's really a
game changer with merch and then
tommy really is a game changer with a
lot of things he's a very inspirational
dude the way he thinks about the
business
and
and
and you know sometimes you're so close
to something you can't see it and
i've been so close tommy i never really
registered like oh yeah i got to do that
[ __ ] too but like merch is like i love
rocking merch of something i'm a fan of
for sure like it's so much fun for sure
because it's like it's like you go
through the grocery store and someone's
like stewie dan you see him at the bowl
and you're like i did and they're like
oh it's a great show like [ __ ] yeah play
too many originals but yeah whatever
he played too much of the news did you
go to the show i didn't go to the show
paul went to the show i really wanted to
see him i like steely danny he was great
it was great you know scott does all my
merch he's yeah the brain child of all
of my operations can we send you some
hot sauce to your place we have i think
we still have we had a case delivered
okay great last time yeah yeah i'll send
you anything you guys want what was the
one
butthole destroyer is the new one if you
want really [ __ ] hot hot sauce and if
you go to amazon and type in the word
butthole
our hot sauce shows up
really we basically have the corner on
the word butthole thank god because if
people type in stevo's butthole they're
not going to see that picture
way to get in front of that one
quick come up with a product come on
[Applause]
racist
oh my god dude that's so [ __ ]
fantastic no it's it's uh
i could i'm obsessed with
i'm obsessed with comedy like i'm
obsessed with it i could do this right
now
all [ __ ] day long that's i mean legit
podcasting is so much fun to me that i
don't consider a job and i'm shocked
that we can't even make money at it and
then stand up i'm so blown away like i
do wednesday nights at the store
i do like uh i'll do the the hack trick
and
and i the other night someone gave me um
uh you know money at the end of the show
it was just let's just i mean i don't
know i'm just so that i'm not calling
anyone out let's let's just say arguably
it's a thousand dollars to do a spot at
the on the main room sam tripoli and uh
my wife was there with her friends and
while you're seeing the same triple
hosted the night it was hosting the
night and then i just did a spot and
then if you know if you're sometimes if
you're a bigger name the guys will give
you a little extra more of the door to
help them sell tickets but they got to
use your name to promote i'm totally
cool with that um
and they always kick you back good money
and it's cash i never have cash on me
but i was i was buzzed and i just done
three shows i was buzzed and i was high
and i had a great time on stage i had a
great time on stage
and i don't normally perform hammered
but i did and it was fun as [ __ ] and i
walked through the bar and i gave the
but weight the bar staff 500 dollars i
gave the doorman a hundred dollars the
other doorman 100 guy in the thing 100
on the ends like and then i got in the
car in the end goes did you just give
away arguably we'll say a thousand
dollars i said yeah she goes why and i
said cause
i don't i was i'd do that for free she
was yeah but you didn't you should keep
the money i said yeah but it feels cheap
like i don't need a thousand dollars it
doesn't change my life but like 500
dollars for that as a person that helps
them oh you just covered my bills for
the month yeah and and i think and rogan
taught us that like he was like i
remember i walked i got the thousand for
whatever thousand dollars he got and i
put in my pocket he goes what are you
doing here you don't need that tip
everyone out and i was like really he's
like you make good money on pot you got
a lot of good things going for you tip
everyone out and so i feel the same way
yeah and so uh
but i do it for free i do all this for
free
yeah dude yeah
um i've got something that i'm [ __ ]
dying to uh i'm trying to find an hour
of your time and show you a recording of
my uh
my current hour i'm dying to see it
i saw the intro is pretty [ __ ]
impressive it's uh it's [ __ ]
explosive dude i'm touring with an
explosive show and i'll have you know
that that uh i'm
about to
schedule the final
uh shows for this tour and then what
comes next is uh
steve has gone too far to her
i love it i i'm inspired by you dude
like i i'm inspired by you i um
i remember when we did the first podcast
in the same van it was like like you
said beta testing the van and and i was
talking about uh you were telling us the
joys of having a tour bus oh my god
and i was saying like yeah like theater
like i think i didn't know that the
wilbur had an upper deck because i guess
it was never open for me and uh dude
like i've come so [ __ ] far
you are you have
you have
man you are the
you're the malcolm gladwell of the 10
000 hours if you put the work in you you
you get good yeah and you just have done
that you just did that and you did it at
times when people didn't want you to do
it and people gave you [ __ ] about doing
it and you just have and and
i'm telling you man as like as like a
fan and i'll always be a fan first
you know for everything i am but like as
a fan you made me laugh so hard
for so many years that is so great to
see you thriving it really thank you man
it means the world to me and um
i uh
i just
i [ __ ] grinded in the comedy clubs
for 11 years nobody knows i was just
quietly grinding yeah and sometimes
catching [ __ ] from people for sure for
sure and i just didn't i never [ __ ]
gave up i just found my own voice
graduated to theaters now i can tell
people about the joys of having a tour
bus even though it's a piece of [ __ ] rv
and and uh
and i look at you in [ __ ] arenas and
i'm like
i just feel like i'm i'm just marching
and i'm [ __ ]
just determined put it in the universe
man i'm telling you put in the universe
and just and just oh like
i mean this is the way i look at it but
like
always be mindful of your set and hope
is a little better today than
today is than it was yesterday for sure
and then if that's if that's just little
increments i remember my little
increments were like ways to comfort me
about this business i remember uh the
first time i sold out comedy clubs and
then i put out like my special and uh
that was the showtime one showtime one
uh no no it was that came after but
first time i sold out comic clubs i
remember saying
saying to tommy it was like i was like
if i could send sell just like
10 more tickets next year that would
make me feel like i did a lot and he was
like bert that's 10
it's a lot of money that would be a lot
of money and i was like yeah he's like
it's a good way to think about it and
then i did and then and then i remember
he was he was like you know you should
think like what if i can just in
increase my ticket price and have the
same people so i was 20 tickets what if
i go to 35 tickets then i could do the
same work for the same people really
grow with the people that trust me and
that i trust in that in those in these
comedy clubs and just make a little bit
more money not a ton just a little bit
more money and i remember doing that i'm
getting [ __ ] for him from some people
but i'm i've always looked at it just
like little increment little incremental
steps make a big difference and then and
then if you rob deer deck it like i said
i'm fascinated by rob deerdack but he
quantifies
the things that make him happy i
quantify the things that
that i hear other comics say they like
about me that you know they're like dude
i love your promos all right cool i'm
not getting [ __ ] about them i'm going to
double down i love your podcast i love
two bears oh people said to me for a
long time i love something's burning
whatever happened with it it was just
complicated and i was like i was like
well let me see if i can take the steps
to get to do it again so p i can make
stuff that people like and so
and so and i think and like i said i
really see so much common ground in the
way we see the world and the way we
operate and the way we run our
businesses
be it me kind of stealing from you and
seeing the way you operate and but uh
but i really think those baby steps
you're gonna be in [ __ ] arenas in no
time
i'm on the march dude i'm on the march
and uh when this this this
hour that i'm dying to show you comes
out as a special no matter how it comes
out as a special
[ __ ] it's good it's [ __ ] it's it's so
[ __ ] good and then theme of my gone
too far tour the theme of the show is me
actually confronting middle age like
actually [ __ ] delving into how
somebody who identifies as adolescent
professionally and in every sense in the
word how and who uses his body as his
instrument and now i'm [ __ ] forced to
deal with the deterioration of my
instrument i'm supposed to force to deal
with becoming [ __ ]
old when my identity is to be young and
like how
the deep [ __ ]
challenging [ __ ] thing that's going
to be so difficult it's this bit that i
i worked on
a long time ago and it never really
worked the premise was i just come out
and say i have a theory i'm pretty sure
god hates us
you know because
like really
our [ __ ] existence is a goddamn prank
on us like [ __ ] about because we have
one instinct which is to survive
but one guarantee which is we won't so
what the [ __ ] is going on here the one
[ __ ] thing that we don't [ __ ] want
to have happen is all that we can be
sure is gonna happen that gives you so
much panic party by the way
you are
you will certainly die
and as as as we [ __ ] barrel towards
this inevitable demise which we [ __ ]
want to have no part in more than
anything else we wilt we are [ __ ] by
we wilt you're giving me a panic attack
and like you know like to put into
perspective like why like i feel god
hates us he's singled out human beings
like a [ __ ] banana
is blissfully unaware that it's bruising
okay like we're like the banana that can
see in the mirror i'm [ __ ] bruising
we're like the carton of milk that that
is aware of its expiration date and
knows that it's a washed up [ __ ]
house you're making me not want to drink
now i'm supposed to be
the purpose of our human existence which
is a ridiculous prank on us is to wrap
our heads around our mortality right
like you know like for whatever that's
worth sell me that pill yeah
and uh and and and like and and i
am i'm having a candidly i don't have
all the answers you know like i looked
in the mirror and i saw that i've
actually developed dimples under i have
underboob actually [ __ ] developing
man boobs i remember that day yeah
i was having sex with my wife and i was
playing with my own kids
what's going on god [ __ ] decided that
that i [ __ ] had to have [ __ ] man
boobs and i'm [ __ ] lashing out dude
you want [ __ ] you tell me i got
assets
you just over ate a little bit i mean
whatever dude whatever dude and and i
genuinely believe that
to to tackle this subject matter to
[ __ ] you know every
huge over-the-top going too far stunt
will be motivated it's going to be
thematic and i think it's going to be
[ __ ] genius i think it's going to be
my mastery but i can't wait to see it
and i think it needs to be in arenas i
think that's a brilliant idea all right
i'm going to go have a drink now guys
you spun me into a panic attack that's
my panic attack this morning
hey i love you brother i love you too
thank you thank you guys
that was [ __ ] great
there you have it folks bert kreischer
what a bro
and uh what can i tell you guys
um we're in texas and i have come down
with a serious case of beaver fever
anybody who's paying close attention to
my main channel youtube videos is gonna
see a whole lot of beef in my next video
and um yeah dude it's been rad got the
bros this is leo
that's uh scott randolph
and show him you jeremy jeremy is the
new star of our team [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah i love you street team thanks
so much everyone